euromax highlights and here's your host
ann o'donnell
hello and a very warm welcome to euromax
highlights let's have a look back at our
favorite reports of the week
the nature of the beast
portraits of the animal kingdom
close shave why retro barbers are making
a comeback
and party marathon seeing and being seen
at the han and cam races
well if you think your pet is part human
or indeed maybe your pet himself thinks
he's part unum human then you're not
alone the brit tim flack an
award-winning photographer also sees the
human nature in animals and captures
their emotional states in his
photography now he has just published a
new picture book evolution
the relationship between humans and
animals is a complex one
what distinguishes humans as a species
and how much animal is there inside of
us
it's these questions that photographer
tim flack explores in his work
the results are portraits that appear
nearly human
some seem to belong on the pages of a
high-gloss advertisement
many have appeared in important
international publications from national
geographic to the new york times
what i'm often wanting to do is place
the animal
you might say out out of its context of
a jungle be it or sahara or in this case
the rainforest
and
pla place it against a neutral
background so that we can explore what
does that animal mean to you
the photos require a great deal of
preparation
tim flack takes most of them in his
london studio
today two reptiles are taking part in
the shoot
animal handler mark amy has a lot of
experience with dangerous animals and
he's been working with flack for years
today he's brought along a jackson's
chameleon
and a horned sand viper an extremely
poisonous snake from the sahara
well both
are
susceptible to high levels of stress
vipers particularly if he starts
striking all over the place and
excavating or sidewinding
that's not such a bad thing because
that's his defense and then he'll settle
and once he's settled that's when we're
going to get the best shot
a plastic model is used to help set up
the lighting
if you come in with it
chameleons are sensitive creatures it's
important not to place the animal under
too much stress
flak studies the animal's natural
behavior during a test run and then he
adjusts his camera settings
he takes just a few photographs
searching for that one special moment
this thing of not knowing quite what
will happen i'm responding to it i'm a
great believer in the creative process
although you may set up the framework
and invite a particular animal with an
idea in mind
the dangers is being too locked into
that
and it's really important to in a sense
let things reveal themselves
his latest book is called evolution and
it's now also been released in germany
it's a collection of his photography
that retraces the animal kingdom from
aquatic creatures to the great apes
tim flack has also had numerous solo
exhibitions
two of his dog portraits have even
graced stamps in britain
he's also done work for major ad
campaigns
he originally studied communication
design before turning to art and
photography
i'm often playing with iconography
in my studio work often referencing
either art or or just a a relationship
to what is the popular cultural
reference to that subject matter
prior to evolution he'd released three
books of his own photographs including
ones on horses and dogs
his portraits of bats are almost
uncannily human
other photos demonstrate how humans
shape and manipulate animals
what i'd like to achieve
is to
really be there as a conduit for as a
visual conduit you might say a visual
kind of catalyst for other voices to use
it to look at some of the debates about
how we
manage animals in the human space
which i believe are some of the
prominent questions that lie ahead of us
the conundrums of our own success as a
species and what that throws up
tim flack is always looking to capture
layers of meaning
like this snake its scales enhanced to
emphasize their primeval quality
his images let us imagine the emotions
of animals and revealed the animal in
all of us
well autobahn is an istanbul based
interior design company with a love of
all things german a turkish design duo
founded autobahn and their work is
heavily influenced by the bauhaus style
it is a sleek look that is very much in
demand right now a photo book displaying
a decade of their work has just been
published we caught up with them in
their home city
furnishings that are understated and
elegant made of wood leather and rattan
the creative team behind autobahn gave a
modern twist to classic designs
we have an important formula
form function and experience
experience is very important because we
don't just make individual pieces
our goal is to give a special and
individual character to entire buildings
autobahn is the work of seifer chalar
and sehan uzdimir
although the name may sound german the
label isn't based in munich or berlin
autobahn is headquartered in istanbul
it's located in beolu a creative
district right on the bus
audubon is one of turkey's most
successful design projects they have 36
staff members working in their 400
square meter studio
and i met in the 1990s at the meemasinan
fine arts university
i was studying architecture and sifa was
studying interior design our creative
styles brought us together and then we
continued that work in our label
autobahn
their shop is located in bashiktas one
of istanbul's upscale districts
a single chair can fetch upward of 4 000
euros
some lamps go for well over a thousand
euros good taste comes with a price tag
their top designs include the bergere
armchair in many variations
and the king lamp
many of their designs have won prizes
including one from the design magazine
wallpaper audubon draws inspiration from
its name
we've been influenced by german
professions who've been shaping our
concept of design layout and
architecture since the 1950s
the german school bauhaus and even the
band kraftwerk
all those things helped inspire our name
audubon's design philosophy is more
elegant than radical their pieces can
often be found in bars restaurants and
hotels
all locations where a variety of tastes
have to merge and co-exist
they completely redesigned two hotels
the bosporus and the nishantashi from
the lobby to the guest rooms
although they have an international
focus the pair prefer living in istanbul
to trend setting cities like london or
new york
i heard
istanbul has always been a melting pot
that brings together a variety of
cultures people and religions
because it's a kind of chaos but one we
benefit from and draw on to become even
more productive
the fruits of their creative labors are
the subject of a new book from the
gestalton publishing house in berlin
over 320 pages it's a survey of 10 years
of autobahn's history
cafes and hotel rooms complete rooms and
exclusive one-off designs
all captured in panoramic photos and
sketches
we've designed more than 300 projects
since 2003 and we've produced more than
80 products it's been an incredibly
creative and productive time
we wanted to document the first 10 years
of autobahn
this year we'll see aroman tackling a
major new project they're developing
tall wooden cocoons that will replace
traditional walls in restaurants and
lounges at azerbaijan's international
airport in baku
people feel small in public buildings
like airports because their needs are
not being attended to
that's why we want to create social
spaces that will give people that sense
of comfort
two rising stars who are still picking
up speed
well in many other countries they're on
all the street corners but here in
germany they had practically vanished
traditional barbershops now though there
is a new trend going on here the
comeback of the beard bearing in mind it
is the styled ones at that at some old
school barber shops they are starting
now to pop up in trendy districts where
you can have a straight razor shave and
get those whiskers back in shape
at home it would just take a few minutes
with an electric razor but here it's a
delicate operation requiring at least 20
minutes of calm and concentration
men in german cities are increasingly
rediscovering the wet shave
traditionally offered by barber shops
some get their hair cut at the same time
others just stop by for a shave
you definitely can't do it as well at
home
and you feel you've treated yourself to
something
you can really feel the difference
david fechner's barbershop in munich
features 1930s furnishings and harks
back to the days when men were gentlemen
the shop has been open for less than a
year
but fechner already gets up to 10
customers a day for his vintage shaves
i love that era with the old furniture
and then when you consider that no one
offers this service for men anymore i
think it's a really nice thing
i can tension the skin better and i work
much more intensively than you would at
home
i take more time and i can shape the
beard much better
and beards are in vogue more than ever
before young men in particular have
become increasingly keen on facial hair
they may opt for the full bed for a
while then change to designer stubble
with carefully defined contours of
course
so it's hardly surprising that expensive
treatments and grooming rituals are
growing in popularity too
the modern barber knows exactly what his
customers want
here
so what are we doing today
customers with beards appear to feel
more comfortable at david fitness barber
shop than at a normal hairdresser
but it's good if someone gives it a
little attention
in berlin nicole whedon's beauty salon
has started offering a full treatment
package for men with beards
this is a vienna and a form from
wellness
it's a kind of wellness treatment for
men that's very pleasant
it allows a man to keep his sense of
masculinity
while still enjoying some pampering
awareness
care products such as beard shampoo
grooming brushes and beard oil are
coming back onto the market they're all
part of the 70 minute king size package
offered by nicole wieden's barber from
new york
straight razors are in such high demand
that german manufacturer burka is
struggling to keep up with demand
still those new to the wet shave prefer
to have an expert on the job
the first time they feel nervous
second time
now
and when they notice
did i
how i work with the beer how i put the
charm
and when they see at the moment how i
start to work with the blade
they get confident
customers pay between 20 and 78 euros
for a personal grooming session at this
berlin barbers
i come here once a week just for a
little re-trim
then once a month i come for a complete
hour-long treatment and haircut
treatment
and the cinema
another trend in germany women are
increasingly treating their men folk to
a visit to the vintage barber ahead of a
special occasion
scruffy is so yesterday
now euromax reporter has covered the
legendary hanon cam skiing competition
for us that finished up last week in
kitzbuh it boasts one of the most
grueling downhill winter slopes so it's
no surprise at all that the apres ski
events are equally as popular there in
fact this was the competition that
caught our attention whose party was the
best organized and which attracted the
most celebrities so we went to party
helping in tyra
with a gourmet gala dinner followed by a
variety show the kitts race party was
certainly among the favorites for title
of best
and there was lots of great food
emails are fabulous i can't complain as
long as the food's hot everything's
great
very glamorous isn't it i'm feeling a
bit underdressed i forgot to pack a tie
but it's you know it's a sexy
celebration of people having a good time
celebrating this amazing race here the
great athletes that have been out
performing
the han and calm down hill counts as the
toughest race on the alpine world cup
circuit
around 90 000 people converged on
kittsburl austria for the event
competitors took the strife course at
over 140 kilometers an hour
an extreme challenge even for the winner
hannes reichelt
celebrity guests also took to the slopes
in the kids charity trophy event before
the evening of partying began
hollywood star arnold schwarzenegger
also made an appearance
it takes the chef all year to plan the
menus for the kids race party
we look for what's new this year what
the latest trends are we take it from
there and develop something special for
kids
the tirolian town is tiny but when it's
party time the competition is fierce
field sausage producer tony holdenberger
has been throwing his veal sausage
parties in the stangle vert hotel's
rustic surroundings for 20 years now
this is a simple homey cozy get-together
you don't need an expensive menu with
lots of courses there's veal sausage
wheat beer and you party with your
friends
it's the first time i've ever eaten veal
sausage it's very tasty
it's original it's a tradition and it
wasn't made up just for fun an authentic
tradition comes to life here the young
people are in good spirits
meanwhile at a party at the hotel
sorting british pop star james blunt was
entertaining the crowd
here chef jurgen bartle is in charge of
the kitchen he uses produce from the
region such as tyrolian veal
his specialty is red beet ravioli
you know i'm an ex-army i eat everything
very happy too
and you know also i taught the world the
thing i really enjoy is trying local
food as a pasta pasta's always a hit and
red beets are healthy so this is just
right for an athlete
i've never had hot beet fruit before in
pasta so the food is more important than
anything i you know i will just smell
the food from a mile away and i'm
the there race party meanwhile was going
full tilt
the menu was designed to fit in with the
location
it's all very brightly colored it's all
about having fun and that goes for
everything from the setup of the tent
here to each and every dish we served
one item on the menu was variations on
golden beets
as long as he doesn't serve red beets
the sheer numbers of celebrity guests
made this year's kids race party a
record setter 1200 people reveled well
into the wee hours of the morning
records are enjoying a comeback and not
just for their retro sound the latest
trend that has hipsters in a spin is
eyewear made out of vinyl a creation by
zach tipton and it all started off in
his dad's garage it was there that his
father stored his old record collection
and where zach came up with the idea to
recycle records as a new and fashionable
product we visited the pioneer of specs
appeal in budapest
zach tipton puts a new spin on records
nobody listens to anymore
but his vinyl isn't for the ears
but for the eyes
vinyl eyeglass frames
they're in the groove literally
the models carry famous names from music
jackson lennon and miles their visual
aids and sun protection
they're the recycled frames of the vinyl
eyes brand and they're more than just a
fashion statement
every time somebody somebody puts on the
frame they know what they're wearing and
i hope it makes them
behave in a more
environmentally responsible fashion you
know and when they think that something
that they're wearing
is inspired by that then it'll influence
their behavior
zak tipton studio in budapest is stacked
full of old phonograph records
when laminated and cut out with a jigsaw
they become eyeglass frames
every frame is made here by hand just as
the first model was in the year 2000
i wanted to make some some frames out of
a different material than metal and i
was in the workshop and i kind of looked
over in the corner and i saw my father's
record collection
and i was like ah why don't i just try
making them out of that and i took a
couple and glued them up and cut them
out and then that's how the idea was
born
zak tipton grew up in the united states
but since 2004 he's been designing and
producing in hungary his mother's home
country
now he's got 15 employees to help him
he finds his raw material in various
record stores around the hungarian
capital
zach tipton is also a record collector
in private
for his eyewear he generally takes the
leftover stock on the bottom shelf
if it's not coming from here it'll come
from old um
distributors that went out of business
they couldn't sell the records the
market collapsed factories went out of
business and they can't send them back
for recycling so these are tens of
thousands of records just sitting in
warehouses
a few hardcore vinyl fans tend to view
tipton's designs with skepticism
i'm not too keen on it i like records
and i think records should be listened
to or maybe hang them up on a wall
i find it a bit morbid to make things
out of them
other music fans are enchanted with the
idea among them elton john hollywood
star michael madsen rapper flow reader
the band 30 seconds to mars and american
movie director quentin tarantino
music stars are both customers and
inspiration for the frames
what we like to do is just take a
musician and examine the the history
that he he lived in
uh what kind of style he wore or if we
were to make jimi hendrix some uh a
frame
how would that frame look would jimi
hendrix wear this or would jim morrison
wear this frame
irish singer-songwriter bono has ordered
a set of frames zach tipton picked out a
very special record as his raw material
it's a vinyl that was pressed in in the
70s
and he went to this concert that uh
collected funds for amnesty
international and he attended this in
june of 1979
and the research i did showed that he
was very influenced by this
zak tipton's company sells as many as
500 frames a month to customers from
around the world the frames start at 300
euros the cases also made a vinyl are
included and a spectacle stand
sometimes people get really upset
because of the cultural damage hey
you're destroying great music and what
about these artists and all that
but you'll people have to realize that
that just like books or anything that
society creates not every one of them is
going to be a masterpiece culturally not
every book is going to become a
classical piece
same with vinyl
zach tipton has found a lucrative new
use for old and unwanted vinyl and given
a whole new meaning to the word groovy
that was some of our favorite highlights
of the week and that is it from me and
o'donnell and the rest of the euromax
crew for today catch up with us online
for more information thanks for watching
bye
you